trap you a ton they'll also go zone a
ton it's a very unique experience when
you go up against this team
irving catch fire and connect from deep
here's brown pushing
[Applause]
irving
cuts inside dances free and lays it in
gorgeous wizardry from kyrie irving
dragons johnson mills irving and claxton
the five for brooklyn
attacking dishing extra feed how about
irving
[Applause]
irving will fire and hit from three
kyrie is locked in
he has 17 points on just five field goal
with him
extra fein draggish
a little too strong another chance here
irving will fire you
kyrie
with 20 already in this first half
understand their best ways to operate on
the floor durant goes cross court irving
finger tips it in on a cross-court pass
from durant
[Music]
kareem slicing through kicking out
irving oh yeah
kyrie with 28 points another chance here
curry
doesn't get the roll another offensive
rebound irving wants it
you bet
kyrie is putting on a show
7-3 on 8-10
15-point game
irving
irving puts it in
33 for kyrie irving it wasn't a secret
formula that changed throughout the
course of that first quarter it was just
a lot of better
you have that guy and that helps that's
a lot of what we've seen from charlotte
here in a second
irving good hands comes up with a steal
irving
racing into the pain irving able to
finish 39
for kyrie irving a new season high
fourth in the turnover
four turnovers now from duran
irving
he's the great equalizer
42
for kyrie and his ninth three of the
evening
irving
five to shoot irving trying to get some
space two to shoot irving elevates and
hits
he's a magician
brown fakes dishes
kyrie
going for the 50 piece irving
has 50.